We know what a chemical equation
is and we've learned
how to balance it.
Now, we're ready to learn
about stoichiometry.
And this is an ultra fancy word
that often makes people
think it's difficult.
But it's really just the study
or the calculation of the
relationships between
the different
molecules in a reaction.
This is the actual definition
that Wikipedia gives,
stoichiometry is the calculation
of quantitative,
or measurable, relationships
of the
reactants and the products.
And you're going to see in
chemistry, sometimes people
use the word reagents.
For most of our purposes you can
use the word reagents and
reactants interchangeably.
They're both the reactants
in a reaction.
The reagents are sometimes for
special types of reactions
where you want to throw a
reagent in and see if
something happens.
And see if your belief about
that substance is true or
things like that.
But for our purposes
a reagent and
reactant is the same thing.
So it's a relationship between
the reactants and the products
in a balanced chemical
equation.
So if we're given an unbalanced
one, we know how to
get to the balanced point.
A balanced chemical equation.
So let's do some
stoichiometry.
Just so we get practice
balancing equations, I'm
always going to start with
unbalanced equations.
Let's say we have iron
three oxide.
Two iron atoms with three
oxygen atoms.
Plus aluminum, Al.
And it yields Al2
O3 plus iron.
So remember when we're doing
stoichiometry first of all, we
want to deal with balanced
equations.
A lot of stoichiometry problems
will give you a
balanced equation.
But I think it's good practice
to actually balance the
equations ourselves.
So let's try to balance
this one.
We have two iron atoms here
in this iron three oxide.
How many iron atoms do we have
on the right hand side?
We only have one.
So let's multiply this
by 2 right here.
All right, oxygen, we have
three on this side.
We have three oxygens
on that side.
That looks good.
Aluminum, on the left hand
side we only have
one aluminum atom.
On the right hand side we have
two aluminum atoms. So we have
to put a 2 here.
And we have balanced
this equation.
So now we're ready to do
some stoichiometry.
There's not just one type of
stoichiometry problem, but
they're all along the lines of,
if I give you x grams of
this how many grams of aluminum
do I need to make
this reaction happen?
Or if I give you y grams of this
molecule and z grams of
this molecule which one's
going to run out first?
That's all stoichiometry.
And we'll actually do those
exact two types of problems in
this video.
So let's say that we were given
85 grams of the iron
three oxide.
So my question to you
is how many grams of
aluminum do we need?
Well you look at the equation,
you immediately
see the mole ratio.
So for every mole of this, so
for every one atom we use of
iron three oxide we need
two aluminums.
So what we need to do is figure
out how many moles of
this molecule there are in 85
grams. And then we need to
have twice as many moles
of aluminum.
Because for every mole of the
iron three oxide, we have two
moles of aluminum.
And we're just looking at the
coefficients, we're just
looking at the numbers.
One molecule of iron three
oxide combines with two
molecule of aluminum to make
this reaction happen.
So lets first figure out how
many moles 85 grams are.
So what's the atomic mass
or the mass number
of this entire molecule?
Let me do it down here.
So we have two irons
and three oxygens.
So let me go down and figure out
the atomic masses of iron
and oxygen.
So iron is right here, 55.85.
I think it's fair enough
to round to 56.
Let's say we're dealing with
the version of iron, the
isotope of iron, that
has 30 neutrons.
So it has an atomic
mass number of 56.
So iron has 56 atomic
mass number.
And then oxygen, we already
know, is 16.
Iron was 56.
This mass is going to be 2
times 56 plus 3 times 16.
We can do that in our heads.
But this isn't a math
video, so I'll get
the calculator out.
2 times 56 plus 3 times
16 is equal to 160.
Is that right?
That's 48 plus 112,
right, 160.
So one molecule of iron three
oxide is going to be 160
atomic mass units.
So one mole or 6.02 times 10
to the 23 molecules of iron
oxide is going to have
a mass of 160 grams.
So in our reaction we said we're
starting off with 85
grams of iron oxide.
How many moles is that?
Well 85 grams of iron
three oxide is equal
to 85 over 160 moles.
So that's equal to, 85 divided
by 160 equals 0.53125.
Equals 0.53 moles.
So everything we've done so far
in this green and light
blue, we figured out how
many moles 85 grams of
iron three oxide is.
And we figured out
it's 0.53 moles.
Because a full mole would
have been 160 grams. But
we only have 85.
So it's point 0.53 moles.
And we know from this balanced
equation, that for every mole
of iron three oxide we
have, we need to have
two moles of aluminum.
So if we have 0.53 moles of the
iron molecule, iron three
oxide, then we're going to need
twice as many aluminum.
So we're going to need 1.06
moles of aluminum.
I just took 0.53 times 2.
Because the ratio is 1:2.
For every molecule of this, we
need two molecules of that.
So for every mole of this, we
need two moles of this.
If we have 0.53 moles, you
multiply that by 2, and you
have 1.06 moles of aluminum.
All right, so we just have to
figure out how many grams is a
mole of aluminum and then
multiply that times 1.06 and
we're done.
So aluminum, or aluminium as
some of our friends across the
pond might say.
Aluminium, actually
I enjoy that more.
Aluminium has the atomic
weight or the
weighted average is 26.98.
But let's just say that the
aluminium that we're dealing
with has a mass of 27
atomic mass units.
So one aluminum is 27
So one mole of aluminium is
going to be 27 grams. Or 6.02
times 10 to 23 aluminium atoms
is going to be 27 grams. So if
we need 1.06 moles, how many
is that going to be?
So 1.06 moles of aluminium is
equal to 1.06 times 27 grams.
And what is that?
1.06 times 27.
Equals 28.62.
So we need 28.62 grams of
aluminium, I won't write the
whole thing there, in order to
essentially use up our 85
grams of the iron three oxide.
And if we had more than 28.62
grams of aluminium, then
they'll be left over after
this reaction happens.
Assuming we keep mixing it
nicely and the whole reaction
happens all the way.
And we'll talk more about
that in the future.
And in that situation where we
have more than 28.63 grams of
aluminium, then this molecule
will be the limiting reagent.
Because we had more than enough
of this, so this is
what's going to limit
the amount of this
process from happening.
If we have less than 28.63 grams
of, I'll start saying
aluminum, then the aluminum will
be the limiting reagent,
because then we wouldn't be able
to use all the 85 grams
of our iron molecule, or our
iron three oxide molecule.
Anyway, I don't want to confuse
you in the end with
that limiting reagents.
In the next video, we'll do
a whole problem devoted to
limiting reagents.